[Música]
muchas veces con diferentes espacios
personales y profesionales hemos
escuchado la frase cada acción cuenta y
realmente no dimensionamos el poder que
tiene porque quizá la consideramos un
poco trillado un tanto romántica o quizá
del todo un poco falsa lo cierto es que
todo lo personal esta frase se ha
convertido en motor e inspiración mi
historia como activista inició como un
rotundo fracaso un día como cualquier
otro por ahí de los primeros años del
2000 me levanté con una idea que no pude
ni quise realmente quitar de la mente me
levanté como una inspiración como un
motivo y con un solo propósito yo quería
hacer volver eso me llevó a emprender mi
camino a la estación de bomberos más
cercana de mi casa y preguntar por los
requisitos para ser bombero voluntario
donde se me indicó que en ese momento
con diferentes consideraciones que
tenían administrativas no habían pólizas
de seguro para poder ser bombero
voluntario
y así de crudo y seco y tan rápido como
llegó murió mi inspiración mi motivo y
mi propósito de ser bombero así dice mi
historia de activismo con ese fracaso lo
cierto es que quizá del todo no murió
sino que como muchas cosas en la vida
este sueño cambio en el sentimiento
siempre fue el mismo ser parte de la
solución y no del problema en la
construcción de un mejor planeta
en resumen salvar al mundo por más
patético que suene e imposible para una
sola persona
hoy algunos años después puede decir que
ese mismo sentimiento forma parte de mi
ser es algo que me motiva a seguir y a
luchar cada día contra la indiferencia y
la complicidad después de formar parte
de algunos espacios unos sociales unos
políticos un un tanto más comunales
puedo decir que encontrado el espacio
donde realmente me siento cómodo pero no
siempre fue así
por eso me tomo la libertad de compartir
en este espacio una reflexión que me ha
llevado a entender que para salvar al
mundo se te necesita tener la respuesta
a cinco grandes preguntas
la primera pregunta es cómo y siento que
la respuesta es que para salvar al mundo
debemos de tener motivación y actitud
entendiendo que no será fácil para nada
será fácil y si estamos motivados y con
una actitud de lucha nuestra energía
quizá no vaya a ser suficiente pero
siempre vamos a tener algo que nos
impulse a dar más la segunda pregunta es
con qué y este con qué nos invita a
saber qué necesitamos de una u otra
forma conocimiento ya sea conocimiento
formal o conocimiento informal pero
primero nosotros tenemos que tener
claridad de cuáles son los principales
problemas que tiene el mundo que tiene
nuestro país que tiene nuestra comunidad
que tiene nuestro barrio para poder
empezar a promover y accionar algunos de
los posibles soluciones que nosotros
tengamos la tercera y desde lo personal
siento que es la más importante con
quiénes
y desde este espacio yo siento creo que
tenemos que considerar es que con todas
las personas cada quien con su diferente
energía cada quien con sus diferentes
motivaciones pero lo cierto es que
necesitamos personas que compartan un
sueño que entiendan de nuestro
sacrificio y que estén dispuestos a algo
en la mano cuando la energía empiece a
bajar porque empiezan a bajar y luego
debemos de pensar desde dónde y lo mejor
es buscar un espacio que me haga sentir
cómoda la actuar es imposible salvar el
mundo desde un espacio donde no hay
cines no hay energía donde no hay
mística ni hay convicción quizá ese
espacio ya existe y nosotros podamos
sumarnos a él pero quizás ese espacio no
existe en este momento y sea nuestra
responsabilidad el crearlo desde cero y
por último como empiezo y aquí yo siento
que todas las grandes travesías y
nuestra energía en esto tiene que
empezar desde lo más simple dando el
primer paso
teniendo estas respuestas poder obtener
claridad de una cosa muchas veces
muchísimas veces tendremos en nuestro
entorno más personas que nos frenan y
nos límite que personas que nos motivan
y nos impulsa porque realmente así es la
vida y eso por qué porque al ser humano
no le gusta el cambio y si bien es
cierto sabemos que nuestro problema está
puede llegar a vivir millones de años
más sin nosotros después de nuestra
extinción el ser humano del todo aún no
entiende que para poder garantizar
calidad de vida actual y futura debemos
de cambiar tenemos que cambiar nuestros
patrones de consumo y de producción que
son realmente insostenibles y hace que
cada día consumamos más recursos cambiar
nuestros hábitos de disposición de
residuos porque lo que nosotros creemos
que es basura realmente no lo es y lo
más importante debemos de cambiar las
prioridades en nuestras vidas para
entender que lo material nos llenaba ha
sido del corazón me ayuda en ecosistemas
contaminados por más cosas que
acumulamos en entornos contaminados nos
vamos a sentir vacíos y estaremos
esta foto es una de las fotos de
nuestras playas esta es la realidad de
nuestro país
esta foto guacalillo una playa ubicado
en puntarenas yo tomé esta foto en una
jornada de limpieza que fue organizada
por diferentes organizaciones no
gubernamentales
incluida la fundación ones y de la cual
yo formo parte
esta foto es costa rica ese es a costa
rica que nosotros no queremos ver es esa
costa rica que nuestra indiferencia nos
hace ignorar pero nuestra
irresponsabilidad hace que sea una
realidad y esta playa como muchísimas
otras son el reflejo de cuerpos de agua
contaminados que llevan nuestros
desechos al mar son ciudades
contaminadas con malas disposiciones de
residuos que hacen que nuestros mares
terminen siendo grandes basureros y si
algo me ha dejado claro el organizar y
participar en estas jornadas de limpieza
de ríos de playas y demás espacios es
que las cinco grandes preguntas deben de
tener ya sus cinco grandes respuestas
porque porque es común escuchar personas
decirle a uno que de nada sirve el
esfuerzo que se realiza porque al final
la contaminación seguirá llegando al mar
porque las personas no cambian sus
hábitos de consumo y de gestión de
residuos y quizás parte es cierto es
cierto por mucho de los esfuerzos de
limpieza que se puedan estar realizando
entender de que eso es paliativo
si no hacemos primero grandes cambios
necesarios el gran problema acá es que
para hacer estos grandes cambios primero
tenemos que hacer incidencia tenemos que
generar sensibilización sobre los
diferentes impactos que generan nuestra
indiferencia
salvar el mundo de mi misión y sé que el
mundo no se salva únicamente porque se
levanten miles de toneladas de plástico
y demás residuos de nuestras playas y
océanos eso lo tengo claro también tengo
claro que el mundo se cambia incidiendo
incidiendo en quienes consumen en
quiénes producen y en quiénes deciden
los rumbos de cada país y es únicamente
se realiza convirtiéndonos en agentes de
cambio para que nuestro ejemplo sea cada
día más replicado y tomando en cuenta
para que nuestro ejemplo las personas
busquen sus trincheras y luchen por un
mejor planeta
hace tiempo creo que hace un par de años
viene la instrucción en una red social
que me llamó mucho la atención y cada
día la tengo muy presente el imagen se
veía un niño sembrando un árbol y un
adulto le preguntaba si él quería
cambiar el mundo solo y el niño con una
sonrisa y con mucha convicción le
respondía que no estaba solo simplemente
estaban dispersos pero ya estaban
empezando a juntarse y es que este mmd
es algo muy claro y es algo que vivo
todos los días cuando nosotros empezamos
a construir utopías cada acción cuenta